We are following breaking news on 8 news
now at five a campus security monitor
has been shot on a local Middle School
campus on the east side of the valley
happened just before 12 30 at Von tobel
middle school and thank you for joining
us at five I'm Brian Loftus I'm Denise
Valdez no students were hurt in that
shooting and right now the suspect
though is still at large that School
located near Pecos and Kerry placed on
lockdown for several hours we have Team
coverage eight New Zealand investigator
Kyle Payne standing by with reaction
from parents but we begin tonight with
Victoria Saha joining us
yeah there isn't a police presence
anymore at Von tobo middle school but
there's still no word of an arrest for
the gunmen as of this afternoon though
it's pretty calm right now earlier today
parents rushed over as soon as they
heard reports of a shooting
here's what we know so far around 12 30
there were reports of shots fired at the
school police say several agencies
rushed over including State Police Clark
County fire department and ccsdpd we did
learn it was a male security guard who
was shot and taken to the hospital
meanwhile police were trying to update
frantic parents saying they were going
room to room to make sure there was no
active threat metro police giving us an
update on how they responded to this
intense situation today
we were able to set up a perimeter and
make entry into the school to make sure
all the kids were safe and which they
were so right now it's an ongoing
investigation
police would not tell us if the suspect
was an adult or a student and they
aren't completely sure where exactly the
shooting occurred on campus but again
right now that gunman still hasn't been
caught the shooting left two Schools on
lockdown avantoble was on hard lockdown
and Jeffers Elementary just a block away
from here was on a soft lockdown until
students were dismissed now my colleague
8 news now investigator Kyle Payne he
was also on scene as students were
released and reunited with their parents
Kyle what an intense situation this
afternoon tell us what the parents were
telling you well that's right Victoria
as you can imagine parents hearing about
a school shooting
raced to campus and parents were
standing close by while police had the
area roped off they were also reassuring
parents that no students were injured
but a lot of it played out over phones 8
news now obtained this video of the
harrowing moments inside one of the
classrooms
[Music]
I also caught up with some families as
they reunited after the lockdown
including these two young sisters who
were confined to separate classrooms
I was more aware about my sister since
I'm the eldest
and my family
um
and
ever since is the alarm just came on the
announcement came on
I was scared and we heard like knocking
from like the police
and handle like moving and once they got
in I was wondering if my sister was also
safe
I spoke with another student who says
they've practiced lockdowns before but
nothing like this reporting in Pecos and
Carrie Kyle Payne eight news now